so enorm und herren schöner mist jetzt
hat die retrowelle auch noch die
weltpolitik erfasst nach wetten dass tv
total und 7 tage 7 köpfe kommt auch der
kalte krieg zurück man fragt sich was am
schlimmsten ist wladimir putin zieht
immer mehr truppen zusammen an der
ukrainischen grenze und ist ja
offensichtlich gerade in einer ganz
schwierigen phase und jetzt rätselt die
welt was eigentlich genau will wie ernst
hat das meinen manche experten glauben
er ist eifersüchtig weil alle nur noch
angst vor china haben das möchte er
ändern droht mitten in europa wieder
krieg doch fürchtet euch nicht unser
bundeskanzler hat die lage genau
analysiert und sendet markige worte
richtung moskau die situation ist sehr
ernst ich habe darauf schon hingewiesen
die gruppen bewegung entlang der
ukrainischen grenze darf man
gar nicht übersehen
sonst bräuchte man eine brille dafür
dass der satz so sinnlos war hat er ganz
schön lange darüber nachgedacht putin
bedroht unter anderem finnland und
schweden wer bedroht den schweden und
damit bullerbü gibt es doch gar nicht
die scandinavia sollen genau wie halb
osteuropa schwören niemals der nato
beizutreten
putin twitter ganz offenbar eine prima
eskalation gegeben hat und setzt ein
bisschen auf die schwäche des westens
wenn man joe biden in letzter zeit so
zuhört hat der wladimir da
möglicherweise gar nicht mal so unrecht
wenn eine invasion stattfindet hängt es
davon ab wie die aussieht es ist eine
sache wenn es ein kleines eindringen ist
und dann wird es diskussionen geben was
wir tun sollten und was nicht
ja wirklich also ein kleines einbringen
so eindringen das wäre nicht so will
quasi 1 1 in münchen
man sagt ja auch jedes invasionen gibt
einen sanktionen gar keine frage reden
und weiter verhandeln sind hier wirklich
mal alternativlos aber wer der aggressor
ist erklärt sich eigentlich von selbst
angesichts von inzwischen fast 120
tausend russische soldaten direkt an der
ukrainischen grenze in russischen medien
ist natürlich die ukraine der böse und
russland eine friedensmacht ja klar der
logische und wie kann wir behaupten
sagen die russen russland würde die
ukraine bedrohen nur weil da auf dem
satellitenbild ein paar raketen
abschussrampen zu sehen sind wenige
flugzeuge plus vielleicht zwei drei
panzer aber auch das kann man gut
erklären genau da an der grenze ist
nämlich zufällig russlands einziges auto
kino für panzer muss ständig repariert
werden weil wenn einem soldaten der film
gar nicht gefällt ja
auch eine art von filmkritiken rambo 3
ist aber auch mist putin will so viel
ist klar europa spalten und genau dabei
assistiert wer leider deutschland ist so
nord stream 2 war nie ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt natürlich
nicht sondern vergrößert unsere
abhängigkeit von russischem gas bei
gleichzeitiger ausweitung der ukraine
trotzdem hat herr scholz bis heute nicht
einmal ganz glasklar ausgesprochen im
kriegsfall ist die röhre futsch ja und
völlig egal welche sanktionen irgendwo
diskutiert wird es findet sich immer
mindestens ein deutscher politiker der
sagt na ja aber das trifft uns dann auch
selber ja entschuldigung was für
sanktionen bleiben denn da noch übrig
anschnallen tod hin hier kommen europas
knallharte sanktions ideen für den
ernstfall wenn du wirklich in der
ukraine einmarschiert sperren wir gerd
schröders instaload nie wieder spannende
erklärvideos über hagebutten dein
lieblings nervengift new york gibt es
dann nur noch auf rezept selber schuld
deine nippel würden den deutschen medien
nur noch gepixelt gezeigt und jetzt
wird's parat wir kaufen nie wieder
russisch brot schmeckt ekg überhaupt
alle euro komischen produkte wird europa
im kriegsfall nicht mehr kaufen da
kannst du dich darauf verlassen diese eu
sanktionen wurden ihm präsentiert von
wodka gorbatschow des wodkas reine seele
konsequenz ist das entscheidende und das
mindeste wäre in dieser brenzligen
situation in der ist natürlich keine
einfachen antworten gibt das mindeste
wäre eine einheitliche und glaubwürdige
drohkulisse des westens kriegen wir
nicht auf die reihe klappt nicht
beispiel soll man jetzt im worst case
wenn er denn eintritt russland vom
internationalen zahlungssystemen swift
ausschließen oder soll man nicht hier
eine besonders poetische antwort ich
hatte ja bereits deutlich gemacht dass
der härteste knüppel nicht immer das
intelligenteste schwert am ende sein
wird
ja die wenigsten knüppel sind schwerter
aber rhetorik und berbalk das ist halt
ein zweischneidiges apple aber mal spaß
an der helme beiseite frau berbalk zeigt
wenigstens klare kante zum beispiel bei
ihrem besuch neulich in moskau wenn ich
da im vergleich an den einen oder
anderen spd-politiker denke klingen da
immer noch viele wie gerd schröder
imitatoren vom original mal ganz zu
schweigen
wenn es da weiter eskaliert glauben sie
dass dann noch sind zwei die gaspipeline
von russland nach deutschland also sich
genommen werden kann die ich verstehe
ihre fragen und wirklich ich würde das
eine mit dem anderen zu tun hat
erschließt sich mir nicht dieses projekt
ist ein genehmigtes projekt
ja liebe kinder das passiert wenn man
jahrelang haarfärbemittel einatmet heute
hat er der ukraine säbelrasseln
vorgeworfen begehrt dabei haben die gar
keine säbel nicht nur knüppel mein gott
was ist denn das mit der spd und nord
stream 2
was ist das man versteht es nicht selbst
junge sitzen haben erschreckend viel
verständnis für die einkreisung ängste
der russen und erschreckend wenig für
die ängste von russlands nachbarn hier
kevin köhler zum ukraine konflikt weil
sich alles in mir dagegen wehrt und das
auch nicht unsere überzeugung als spd
ist dass man potenzielle internationale
konflikte herbeireden sollte oder
vielleicht sogar eine gewisse
obsessionen entwickelt
über 100.000 soldaten herbeireden das
schaffen nicht immer die ehrlich
brothers deutschland hält sich so weit
wie möglich raus aus dem ganzen ukraine
ding um die russen nicht unnötig zu
verärgern und bevor wir jetzt wieder als
kriegstreiber beschimpft werden ja es
gibt gute nicht zuletzt historische
gründe für deutschland keine waffen zu
liefern aber man darf sich bitte auch
nicht lächerlich machen zum beispiel mit
sowas hier der hand es sofort geprüft
und wir werden 5000 helme an die ukraine
liefern auch als ganz deutliches signal
wir stehen an eurer seite an eurer seite
also weiter hinten an der seite man
stellt sich das bildlich vor wie die
verzweifelten ukraine die pakete aus
deutschland aufmachen muss sagen ja
helme hey warum nicht meine sonne helm
kann man zum beispiel werfen wenn den
einer direkt an die arme kriegt außerdem
schickt mir nicht nur helme sondern auch
ein feldlazarett also liefern und
aufbauen müssen dass unsere nato partner
aus estland ist wahrscheinlich so ein
ikea bausatz ja wirklich war deutschland
finanziert der ukraine ein feldlazarett
das ist ungefähr so als ob jemand auf
der straße furchtbar verprügelt wird
dann kommt die polizei guckt aber nur zu
und spendiert dem opfer immerhin einen
verbandskasten ja das wäre die analog
meine klar der standpunkt der ampel
keine waffenlieferungen in krisengebiete
das ist ein ehrenwerter wenn wir das
jetzt wirklich auch konsequent
durchziehen dann kann sich die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie aber warm anziehen
muss man sich sorgen machen um eine
erfolgs branche ich frag mal direkt im
nachbar studio nach da moderiert nämlich
till reiners die laufende sendung beim
shopping 24 so leute und jetzt gilt es
wieder anrufen anrufen anrufen nur noch
34 stück übrig von der wunderbaren
panzerhaubitze 2000 von krauss maffei
wegmann eine absolute spitze und wer
jetzt zehn von den babys bestellt krieg
ich drehe durch eine panzerfaust gratis
dazu und diesen gurken rubel m flächen
camouflage look oben bis der oscar ein
es sind ja super gelaunt ja wenn sie
noch gar nicht gehört deutschland
liefert keine waffen mehr in
krisengebiete
marke klar wenn man sich um einen
industriezweig sorgen machen muss dann
um unseren welche sie müssen erstmal
nachrichten gucken die bundesregierung
hat im vergangenen jahr rüstungsexporte
für
9,35 milliarden euro genehmigt und damit
mehr als je zuvor neuer rekord waffen im
wert von über 9 milliarden fünf davon
beim wahnsinns räumungsverkauf der groko
in den letzten neun tagen ihrer amtszeit
merkel hatte ihren figuren aus dem büro
geschleppt haben sie im
bundessicherheitsrat aber auf den hot
button vor allem ergibt dann richtig
zugeschlagen als hauptabnehmer über 4,3
milliarden euro unter top kunde
2021 ein
salutschuss auf die groko
ja aber alt ist ägypten mich an kriegen
beteiligt ja klar sonst bräuchten sie
keine waffen oder um es mit franz josef
strauß zu sagen ich verstehe überhaupt
nicht was waffen in nicht
spannungsgebieten verloren haben
ergebnis im jemen dabei und im libyen
konflikt und wir liefern den waffen ja
wie kommt man denn in länder liefern in
denen menschenrechte mit füßen getreten
werden völliger blödsinn so viele
menschenrechte gibt es da ja gar nicht
geht es sowieso nur eine methode um die
vorfreude auf den frieden zu erhöhen und
wenn du jetzt sagst was ist mit kleinen
armen ländern wie sich diese tollen
deutschen premium waffen gar nicht
leisten können wurde frage oliver klar
haben wir auch was für den kleinen
geldbeutel
wer die pistole nicht ehrt ist den kampf
steht nicht wert zum beispiel haben wir
bis neulich auch kasachstan beliefert
das wurde dieses jahr aber leider kurz
gestoppt weil die diktatur da wohl auf
demonstranten schießt und der präsident
meinte ich habe der armee und den
sicherheitsbehörden befehl erteilt ohne
vorwarnung das feuer zu eröffnen aus dem
ausland werden wir aufgefordert zu
verhandeln und eine friedliche lösung zu
finden was ich ein geräusch
was da für uns immer blöd wenn
diktatoren das so offen aussprechen aber
keine angst die beliefern wir auch bald
wieder deutschland ist der viertgrößte
lieferant von rüstungsgütern in der welt
hier ein ehemaliger cdu abgeordneter
bringt das geschäftsmodell perfekt auf
den punkt wir arbeiten zwar nicht immer
draht mit den leuchtturm der
menschlichkeit und der demokratie
zusammen mit glaubt er würde auch jeder
im zweifel zustimmen aber man muss auch
manchmal nehmen was da ist so nämlich
nehmen was da es ist wie nachts um vier
auf der schönen wetter
aber moment mal die ampel hat doch jetzt
angekündigt bei rüstungsexporten viel
restriktiver zu sein
ja wenn eine regierung so sagt wenn sie
anfängt zu regieren und gewinnst wissen
sie wer mit in dem groko sicherheitsrat
gesessen hat der unter anderem den
fetten ägypten durch geborgenheit
ja und der hat ja nun mit der ampel
wirklich gar nichts zu tun
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die mk